[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى
الشافلي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من رام الله
بعد افراج سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن
الاسير فؤاد الشوبكي بعد قضائه 17 عاما في
سجونها
والى نيويورك حيث عادت بورصه الى مستويات
ايجابيه بعد افتتاح شهد هبوطا ثم جلستين
شهدتا تراجعا حادا على خلفيه افلاس ثلاثه
بنوك امريكيه في الايام الاخيره
والى ساندييغو في كاليفورنيا حيث يعقد
الرئيس الامريكي بعد نصف ساعه من الان
اجتماعا مع رئيسي الوزراء الاسرائيلي
والبريطاني في القاعده البحريه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
معارك وعنيفه للسيطره على وسط بخموت في
اوكرانيا كيف تقول ان ميليشيا بجنر تهاجم
من جهات عده لاختراق دفاعات الاوكرانيه
وتتعهد بعدم الانسحاب وفي تداعيات الحرب
على الجوار وزير الدفاع مولدوفا يقول ان
بلاده لا تواجه خطرا عسكريا وشيكا بل حربا
تقودها موسكو لقلب السلطه
من واشنطن الى عواصم اوروبيه جهود متسارعه
لاحتوائ تداعيات انهيار بنك سلكن فالي
واغلاق بنكشر بايدن يتعهد بالحفاظ على
النظام المصرفي تراجع ثم انتعاش في بورصه
تهاوي اسهم بنوك امريكيه لندن تعلن
استحواذ بنك اتش اس بي سي على الفرع
البريطاني لبنك
ولجنه ازمه المانيه تبحث التداعيات
وبدا عشرين شهرا من حل البرلمان السابق
بدء جلسات برلمان تونسي جديد محدود
الصلاحيات وجبهه الخلاص وحزب النهضه
يعلنان عدم الاعتراف بالمجلس النيابي
ويصفانه بالثمره دستور الانقلاب انتقادات
لمنع الصحفيين من تغطيه جلسه البرلمان
وسيد يطالب اعضاء البرلمان بوضع تشريعات
تناسب اراده الشعر
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياق وتداعيات انعقاد
البرلمان التونسيه على مشهد الازمه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
المتصاعده لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم ماذا بعد انعقاد الفلامان التونسي
بتشكيلته الجديده النتيجه جاءت على النحو
التالي
16% توقعوا حللت الازمه روسيا انما صوت
واحد واربعون في المئه لصالح خيار المزيد
من التعقيد
43% راوا ان المشهد سيراوي مكانه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
وفي فقره المتابعه نرصد اوضاع المعتقلين
في السجون المصريه فترات حبس احتياطي تمتد
لسنوات رسائل مسربه تشكو للانتهاكات وعدد
وفيات في تصاعد
[موسيقى]
اعلنا جيش الاوكراني خلدا جنوده معارك
داميه لمنع القوات الروسيه من السيطره على
وسط مدينه بخت شرقيه البلاد ونقلت مراسله
الجزيره عن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قولها ان
القوات الروسيه تتقدم من الجهه الشماليه
الغربيه من بخموت ياتي هذا بينما وصف رئيس
شركه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه فيني
الوضع في ضخمه بانه صعب للغايه وظيفا ان
الاوكرانيين يتشبثون بكل متر في المدينه
ويصلهم الدعم دون توقف وبامدادات لا نهايه
لها بحسب قوله
واضافين على حسابه في تيليجرام انه مع
تقدم القوات الى وسط باخموت تزداد المعارك
ضراوه لكن التقدم يستمر بفضل قوته وبفضل
السلاح الروسي ونفى رئيس فاجنر وجود اي
خلاف او نزاع بين مقاتلي فاجنر والقوات
المسلحه الروسيه
اما قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الكسندر سيرسكي فقال ان الوضع حول بخمه لا
يزال صعبا مؤكدا ان وحدات فاجنر الهجوميه
تتقدم من عده اتجاهات في محاوله لاختراق
دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه والتقدم الى
احياء وسط المدينه ونشرت القوه البريه في
الجيش الاوكراني صورا تظهر قائد القوات
البريه وهو يتفقد قواته على الجبهه
الشرقيه واضاف بيان عسكري ان تلك القوات
تعمل على اجبار القوات الروسيه على التخلي
عن الهجوم وذلك من خلال تكبيدها خسائر
كبيره
اذا لم تتمكن القوات الروسيه من حسمي
معركه باخموت التي تخوضها ميليشيا فاجنا
الرغبه مروري اشهر على انطلاقها ورغم
صعوبه وضعها تستميت القوات الاوكرانيه في
الدفاع عن المدينه هذا الوضع بدا يطرح
علامات استفهام بشان اهداف الطرفين من هذه
المعركه
معركه بخموت مستمره منذ سبعه اشهر هي اطول
معارك حرب اوكرانيا واكثرها دمويه حقق
الروس تقدما كبيرا وحاصروا المدينه من عده
جهات لكن الاوكرانيين مصرون على الدفاع عن
المدينه يؤكد اغلب الخبراء العسكريين لا
تشكل اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره ولن يغير
مصيرها مجال الحرب لكن رئيس الاوكراني
يبلغ قال ان سقوطها سيمكن الروس من الذهاب
ابعد ليصلوا الى كراماتورسك وسوفيانسك وان
الطريقه سيكون مفتوحا امامهم لما حزيرنسكي
الى امكانيه الانسحاب من لكن قواته تدافع
عنها باستماته فلماذا كل هذا الاصرار على
الدفاع عن ضخمه بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيين
تكتسبه اهميه على المستويين الرمز
والعسكري على المستوى الرمزي تحولت ضخموت
الى رمز للمقاومه الاوكرانيه بعدما كانت
ماريو بول هي الرمز خلال مرحله من الحرب
قبل سقوطها بيد الروس اما على المستوى
العسكري فان معركه تمكن من انهاك القوات
الروسيه المقاتله هناك وتحديدا ميليشيا
افاجنر اذ تقول وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
ان سبعه جنود الروس يسقطون مقابل كل جندي
اوكراني لا يمكن التاكد من هذا الرقم لكن
المعروفه ان القوات المهاجمه تدفع ثمنا
اكبر من القوات التي تدافع عن مكان تحت
سيطرتها ويبدو ان هناك هدفا اخر عبرت عنه
وسائل اعلام قريبه من الجيش الاوكراني
التي تحدثت عن ان الصمود في بوخموت هدفه
ان يبدا الروس في ضرب بعضهم هنا اشاره الى
الخلافات بين قوات فاغنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه فقد انتقد قائد
عده مرات وزاره الدفاع وقياده اركان الجيش
وقال انه لا يحصل على الذخيره وان هناك
عرقله لتحرك قواته الذي استعد للاحتفال
باسقاط بخبوت مع ما يعنيه ذلك من توسيع
للنفوذ في موسكو بدا يشتك صعوبه المعارك
في ضخمه معهد دراسه الحرب اي اس دبليو
يتحدث عن سعي من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لتحقيق هدفين في بخمه انهاك قوات فاجنر
وتقليص نفوذ القائدها في موسكو والحاق
اكبر قدر من الاضرار بالقوات الاوكرانيه
بالنسبه الى روسيا ايضا تكتسي معركه بخموت
اهميه الرمزيه لان اسقاطها سيشكل اول نصر
كبير في الحرب منذ اشهر هي اذا حرب داخل
الحرب تتعدى ابعادها المدينه الصغيره التي
اختفت معالمها تقريبا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك معنا في الاستوديو الان يعني لا اعتقد
ان احد يتابع كل شارده ووارده في الحرب
مثلك عميد الياس وهذا يدفعني للسؤال عن
هذه المرحله بخصوص
ممكن اطرح عليك ثلاثه اوصاف اطلب منك ان
تختار الاقرب للواقع
اولا الروس يتقدمون ببطء ويتكبنوا
ويتكبنون خسائر كثيره ام ان الاوكرانيين
يدافعون عن هذه المدينه ببساله ولكن
الهزيمه بوادر الهزيمه تلوح ام اننا
بمرحله لا غالب ولا مغلوب كما توصف على
المدى البعيد ستسقط هذه المدينه لانه هذه
المدينه تعتبر رمز نصر ليبريكوجين بالحد
الادنى لان هناك خلاف دائما بين وزاره
الدفاع وحتى الرئيس بوتين حذره بطريقه غير
مباشره اثنين نحن في مرحله جديده الجيش
الاوكراني يدافع الى اقصى درجات الدفاع
لعده اهداف واحد استنزاف القوات
وبالتالي الوصول الى ما يسمى بالامتداد
الاقصى هناك بالحروب مفهوم يقال الكلبنيشن
يعني ان يصل القوات الى درجه تستنزف قادر
على الاستمرار هذا الهدف ولكن دائما حسب
ما قال قائد القوات البريه
انه نحن لدينا هدف من هذه المقاومه واحد
كسب الوقت انزال الخسائر وبالتالي ترك
مجال للاستعداد للمرحله القادمه ليلى
المرحله القادمه هي الاساس وهذا ما يتم
التحضير له من قبل الجيش الاوكراني شراء
الوقت يعني اكيد يعرف ذلك ويتكبد خسائر
كبيره ولكن مستميت في الدفاع عن هذه
المدينه ومستعد الى يختلف مع واشن بشانها
واشنطن تقول له ليست بتلك الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه هو مصر هل هي يعني تستحق هذه
الاستماته في هذه المرحله هي انتقلت من
معركه عسكريه بحثه ليلى الى معركه سياسيه
يعني اصبحت رمز اساسي بالنسبه له هو دخل
في اللعبه اصبحت الخسائر متصل الى مرحله
اذا الخروج منها يعتبر خساره كامله ولا
يمكن له الخروج بعد هذه الخسائر اثنين هو
ينزل الخسائر بطريقه كبرى وقوات الروسيه
وهو قال قتيل واحد اوكرانيا مقابل سبعه
وهذا يعطي اساس ولكن على المدى البعيد لا
يمكن ان تدخل اوكرانيا بحرب استنزاف مع
خلل كبير بتوازن قوى خاصه البشريه ولكن
الحرب الشتاء يعني الان ينحسر والربيع على
الابواب والكل يتحدث عن معركه كبيره هل
هذا لصالح روسيا الان ام لصالح اوكرانيا
اليوم نتحدث ليله عن جبهه تقدر بالالف
كيلومتر تبدا من كوبيانسك
وبالتالي
نزولا الى وحتى اجلدار حتى الان لم يثبت
الجيش الروسي انه جاهز لحرب شامله وكامله
يعني اليوم الفريقان
لدى الهجوم يجب ان توضع الاولويات يعني
اهداف الفريقين كبيره جدا والوسائل
المتوفره قليله جدا اذا يجب تحديد
الاولويات يعني تثبيت جبهه والهجوم في
جبهه اخرى وهذا موضوع يدخل موضوع
مخمود تثبيت في مكان والهجوم قد يكون وهذا
ما سنتابعه اكيد خلال الايام القادمه شكرا
جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا على وجودك معنا
هنا
[موسيقى]
في
والان الى ملف اخر تماما في اول كلمه له
عقب تفجر ازمه انهيار بنك سيليكون بالي
الامريكي قال الرئيس جو بايدن ان النظام
المصرفي الامريكي امن وانه لن تكون هناك
ايه خسائر تترتب على دافع الضرائب واضاف
انه يجب محاسبه المسؤولين عن هذه الازمه
واكد بايدن ان ما حصل مع بنكي سلكن فالي
والسيدنتشر لن يتكرر وانه سيطلب من
الكونجرس تشديد القوانين المتعلقه
بالمصارف
بفضل الاجراءات السريعه التي اتخذتها
اداره خلال الايام الماضيه يجب على
الامريكيين ان يكونوا واثقين بان النظام
المصرفي امن والودائع موجوده عندما
تحتاجونها والاعمال الصغيره في كافه انحاء
البلاد يجب ان تتنفس السعداء جميع العملاء
الذين لديهم مدائع في هذه البنوك ليطمئنوا
بان ودائعهم محميه وسيكون لديهم امكانيه
الوصول الى اموالهم منذ اليوم بمن في ذلك
اصحاب الشركات الصغيره من اجل دفع الرواتب
وابقاء شركاتهم مفتوحه
وشهدت مؤشرات سوق الاسهم الامريكيه حاله
من التارجح اثر الصدمه التي خلفها انهيار
بنكي سلكن فالي وسجنتشر وسجلت الاسهم
هبوطا ملحوظا صباح الاثنين ثم عادت لترتفع
في وقت لاحق ومنها مؤشرات عدد من البنوك
بالاضافه الى مؤشري داود جونز وناسك ياتي
ذلك تزامنا واتجاه المستثمرين الى السندات
الحكوميه الامن
وفي بريطانيا اعلنت بنك hsbc في بريطانيا
استحواذه على فرع بنك سلكن فالي في
المملكه المتحده وقال وزير الخزانه
البريطانيه ان الحكومه بالتنسيق مع بنك
انجلترا المركزي سهلت عمليه الاستحواذ
لضمان ودائع بمليارات الجنيهات تعود
لشركات التكنولوجيا الناشئه وكان الفرع
البريطاني للبنك الامريكي انهار بعد تراجع
قيمه اسهم شركات التكنولوجيا في الولايات
المتحده وارتفاع نسبه الفائده الامريكيه
والبنك المركزي على مدى اليومين الماضيين
تكللت بانقاذ الفرع البريطاني لبنك
سيليكون فالي الامريكي والاستحواذ عليه من
قبل بنك
اكبر المصارف الاوروبيه وزير الخزانه
البريطاني اعلن ان الودائع بالبنك امنه
وانه لم يتم استخدام اموال دافعيه الضرائب
في العمليه
بلغت قيمه الشراء الرمزيه جنيها واحدا لكن
بنك اعتبر الصفقه استراتيجيه فعدد
المذيعين فيه 3000 من قطاع التكنولوجيا
والشركات الناشئه وتقدر قيمه الودائع بنحو
السبعه مليارات جنيه تقول الحكومه ان
تداعيات انهيار البنك لم تكن تشكل خطرا
على النظام المصرفي في البلاد لكن بعض
المحللين يرون ان الحكومه لم تتمكن من
طمانه اسواق المال
ربما كان هناك خطر على شركه التكنولوجيا
الصغرى وليس على القطاع المصرفي بشكل واسع
وتحرك البنك المركزي والخزانه السريع
والحاسم لبعث رساله فقط ولم يكونوا يرغبون
في ان يتفاقم الوضع ومن دون شك كان هناك
ضغوط امريكيه بضمان التعامل مع الفرع
البريطاني
تدخل الحكومه لمنع البنك من الانهيار لقي
ترحيبا بين اوساط العاملين في قطاع
التكنولوجيا وهو ما من شانه ان يعزز
مصداقيه الاسواق في خطه الحكومه لانعاش
الاقتصاد البريطاني بعد الفوضى التي
شهدتها عقب اعلان الميزانيه المصغره
لرئيسه الوزراء السابقه
المتحده ولو انه لم يكن على حساب دافعيه
الضرائب يثير تساؤلات بشان متانه مصارف
عده وما اذا كان سيؤثر على سياسات البنك
المركزي خصوصا تلك المتعلقه باسعار
الفائده مينا حرب الجزيره لندن
وينضمن الان الينا من واشنطن
كبير الباحثين بمعهد السياسه الاقتصاديه
في واشنطن اهلا بك
في الحصاد ما هي الاثار الفوريه والطويله
الامد
لانهيار بنك سلكن فالي برايك
في صوري
نحن نتحدث عن اثار
للزياده السريعه من قبل
مصرف المركزي الامريكي الذي دفع هذا
المصرف لانهيار والافلاس ايضا احد
اسباب الاخرى تعود لعام 2018 في
الامريكيه يعتقد كان هناك ضغط على مجموعه
من المصاريف ومن بينها هذا المصرف وكان
هناك ايضا قانون يعود الى الازمه التي
شهدها العالم في
2008 واعتقد ان هذا
السبب هو الذي دفع هذا البنك
هد فعلا ما نراه
ما حصل في 2008 يعني اليس لم تكن هناك
دروس تم الاستفاده منها فيما يتعلق بسوق
قروض العقار
الامر مختلف بعض الشيء 2008
كان الامر يتعلقها بازمه ماليه عالميه
بسبب
العقار في ذلك الوقت والانهيار العقاري
الذي شهدناه في ذلك الوقت ايضا اسعار عقار
لم يشمل ذلك فقط الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن العالم باسره
لكن الان
نتحدث عن الكثير من المال الذي ايضا في
السابق كان هناك اموال كثيره قادمه من
الصين اغرقت الاسواق الان الامر مختلف بعض
الشيء وكما اسلفت هنا دخل المصرف المركزي
الامريكي على الخط
واعتقد ان الزياده التي شهدناها كانت
بالنسبه او مرات واعتقد هذا اثر على اداء
المصرف الان ايضا
بعد مسؤوليه ليس المصرف المركزي الامريكي
فقط الذي دخل على الخط ما دخل على الخط
ايضا
البنك البريطاني يعني السرعه التي دخل بها
على الخط واستحوذه على الفرع البريطاني من
بنك السيليكون فالي هل هو مع مؤشر
في سوق الاقتصاد والقطاع المصرفي على
الاقل في بريطانيا
اعتقد ان هذا مجهود منسق من قبل المتحده
الامريكيه وايضا بريطانيا من اجل
تطمين القطاع المصرفي عبر العالم واعتقد
ان مجموعه من المصارف الكبرى
الذي اغتنم هذه الفرصه من اجل تقويه موقعه
في السوق الماليه العالميه طبعا
حوالي 200 مليار دولار واعتقد
الاستثمار في هذا المصرف الذي النهار سبقه
جيده طبعا عندما تحدث ازمه ثريه لكن
بالنسبه للسؤال الاكبر هل
المصرف
المركزي الامريكي سيتخذ اجراءات حاسمه
واضحه من اجل وقف التضخم وما هي التي
سترتب على ذلك الى استمر المصرف في رفع
نسب الفائده فنحن سنواجه
بالتاكيد الكثير من الازمات لان هذا سيؤثر
على الفقراء لن يؤثر على السيليكون
فالي واصحاب المال والاموال والرؤوس
الاموال هناك لكن على ضعاف الناس والفقراء
في العاده هم من يدفع الثمن على العموم
سنتابع تداعيات ما يجري على السوق
الاقتصادي ليس فقط في امريكا وانما في
اوروبا والعالم كله شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من
واشنطن
كبير الباحثين في معهد السياسه الاقتصاديه
في واشنطن
[موسيقى]
الى تونس ساحه اختار نواب البرلمان الجديد
ابراهيم بودرباله رئيسا للمجلس النيابي
باغلبيه الاصوات متقدما على منافسه عبد
السلام الدحماني وكان البرلمان التونسي
عقد اليوم جلسته الافتتاحيه وسط احتجاجات
في صفوف الصحفيين بعد منعهم من دخول مقر
البرلمان لتغذيه الجلسه وقد رفضت المعارضه
لاعتراف بالمجلس وصفه اياه بثمره دستور
الانقلاب
بعد اكثر من عام ونصف منذ حله واغلاقه
بقرار من الرئيس قيس سعيد فتحت ابواب
البرلمان للنواب الجدد لكنها اوصدت امام
الصحفيين
ومن اوكد واجباتنا كانواب شعب ان نعمل صلب
المؤسسه التشريعيه في كنف التشاركيه
والانسجام الايجابي
مع مكونات السلطه التنفيذيه من منطلق
الايمان بوحده الدوله كي نتجاوز هذه
التحديات الجسيمه
بتركيبه تغيب عنها المعارضه وتطغى عليها
الوجوه الجديده في عالم السياسه ينطلق عمل
البرلمان الجديد
منقوصا من نواب دوائر الخارج في انتظار
استكمال انتخابهم يترافق ذلك مع جدل محتدي
من حول صلاحياته التي نص عليها الدستور
والتي سيتقاسم بموجبها المهام التشريعيه
مع رئيس الجمهوريه ومجلس الجهات والاقاليم
الذي لم تتحدد تواريخ انتخابه بعد
هذا البرلمان تم وضعه اعتقد فقط لارضاء
بعض الاطراف قيس سعيد هو اليوم تحول الى
نظام رئاس الى وجود لهذا البرلمان بنسبه
اليه اليوم هذا البرلمان وجوده فقط يعني
على مستوى الشكل ان هناك مؤسسه برلمانيه
تشتغل اما المعارضه فتواصل خوض صراعاتها
مع السلطه من خارج دوائر المؤسسات الرسميه
جبهه الخلاص التي قاطعت الانتخابات
الاخيره تتمسك بعدم اعترافها بالمجلس
النيابي الجديد بوصفه منبثقا عن دستور غير
شرعي على حد تعبيرها يقول الرئيس قيس سعيد
ان البرلمان الجديد سيكون معبرا عن اراده
عامه وليس عن اراده جهات بعينها لكن هذا
البرلمان الذي بدا اعماله بعيدا عن عدسات
المصورين والصحفيين هو في نظر المعارضه
وجه من اوجه هيمنه الرئيس المتزايده على
السلطه ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد في لقاء مع
مسؤولين محليين في منطقه غار الدماء
الشماليه البلاد انها على المشرعين الذين
بشروا اعمالهم اليوم في مجلس النواب ان
يضعوا التشريعات المناسبه لاراده الشعب
وان لا ينسوا ان الشعب قد يسحب منهم
الوكاله بعد سنه اذا لم يلتزموا بوعودهم
لناخبيهم حسب قوله وقال الرئيس التونسي
انه ستقع محاسبه من يعتبر نفسه امتدادا
لحزب او تنظيم او مجموعه ما لان المرافق
العموميه تقوم على مبدا الحياد
وحتى المشرع الاجتماع في جلسه اليوم
الاولى الافتتاحيه عليه ايضا ان يضع
التشريعات الملائمه ليرات الشعب
وانهم مسؤولين امام الشعب وانا نواب
قادرين باش يسحبوا منهم الوكاله بعد سنه
اذا لم يبدلوا العنايه المطلوبه
للبرنامج اللي تقدموا به للناخبين
سيثني الرئيس عن برنامجك
شكرا
على ما اراده الشعب بان الدستور الذي وضع
في 25 جويليه وضعه الشعب وصوت عليه مواطن
هم من اختاروا هذا النظام وهم من اختاروا
كيفيه وصول هذه النواب الى البرلمان ولكن
الرئيس هو من يمنع الصحفيين ان يدخلوه
بمعنى ان الرئيس له السلطه التي تمنع حتى
جزء من الشعب وهو الصحافيين الذين يفترض
ان يلعبوا دور المراقبه الممنوعين
شكرا لكن انت لديك المعلومه ان الرئيس
لكن ليس هناك منعا من الرئيس الجمهوريه
سعيد واكد لك ذلك ان الرئيس سعيد لم يتدخل
في هذا البرنامج وانما هذا قرار اداري
اتخذته اداره مجلس الشعب لان هناك اداره
مجلس الشعب اتخذت هذا القرار وهذا ليس
بالغريب خلينا نقوله كل العالم هل هناك
الكونغرس هل يدخله الصحفيين طبعا لا هناك
هيئه هناك هناك هيئه اعلاميه تمد الصحفيين
بكل المعلومات في تونس عندما كانت تونس
افريقيا للانبياء وكذلك عنا تنسى الوطنيه
وتستطيع هذا الصور التي تمثل الان على
الشاشه من داخل البرلمان هي من من
تقدم الصوره
ولكن دعني انتقل الى مراد اليعقوبي
واسعن مدى فاعليه تنسيقيه البرلمانيين في
المهجر حكومه منسى ام صرخه غضب واستياء لا
اكثر
بالنسبه تقصدين يعني الذين في المنفى نعم
هل هي حكومه من فهل هذا ما يتطلعون اليه
الحديث عن تنسيقيه للبرلمانيين ما المراد
بها
نعم في الواقع يمكن يمكن ان نصفها بذلك
وان كان هم انفسهم لم يسموا انفسهم بهذا
بهذه الصفه ولكن عمليا ليس هناك حلول اخرى
لان طبيعه الاحزاب في الوضعيات
الديمقراطيه هي احزاب غير لا تمتلك قوه
صلبه لا تمتلك الا وسائل مدنيه للتظاهر
للتعبير او غير ذلك او عندما تحاول ان
تعبر عن ارائها في اماكن اخرى بعيده عن
البلاد عندما يصبح من الصعب عودتها او
التئامها او ما شابه ذلك لا سيما وان
محاوله اجتماع البرلمان والتي تمت عن بعد
قد تمت معاقبه المشاركين في ذلك والى الان
ما زالت الناس تعاني من هذا الوضع
وبالتالي طبيعي جدا ان لا تكون هناك وسائل
افضل من هذا هذه طبيعه العمل للبرلماني
وعمل المدني والسياسي عامه يعني ليست
اسلحه اكثر مما هي متوفره وبالتالي الان
الطريق مفتوح لقيس سعيد ليواصل تجاوزه
للقوانين وذلك
ويفرض برلمان باقل من 10% ويفرض على هذا
البرلمان ان تكون الا تكون له كتل بل ان
تصريح الرئيس لما يسمى بالبرلمان الجديد
اليوم يقول ان سنعمل ككتله ككتله واحده
وهذا من غرائب الامور خلافا لما
يدعيه البعض بان هذا من الامور العاديه
وتحصل في عدد الدول لا نعرف ان انظمه
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه قادره على الحياه يمكن
ان تعيش بهذا الشكل هناك تضيقات واضحه نعم
التضييقات واضحه يعني ان تتحدثت عن معاقبه
عن بعد واعود اليك احمد الهمامي ولكن يبدو
ان هناك معاقبه لمن هم داخل البرلمان
اليوم فقط وبعد اداء اليمين الدستوريه تم
ايقاف وجدي الغاوي على خلفيه اتهامات له
بانه في التزوير بجمع الاصوات للترشح
الامر الذي اساء احتجاجات اليس هناك حصانه
لنواب البرلمان
ليست هناك حصانه لاي شخص في البرلمان ما
دامت تتعلق به شبهات قانونيه نحن كشعب
تونسي اردنا ذلك ووضعناه في الدستور عندما
يكون النائب هو في الحصانه فقط بواجبه
البرلماني لا توجد حسنات حصانه او حصانات
على كل من يخالف القانون ويزور او او
يكونوا متلبسا من اخطا امام القانون سوى
نائب سوى رئيس دوله سوى وزير هل هناك قضاء
عادل في تونس ويقفل له كل حريات
والديمقراطيه وكل المحاكمه العادله لكل
شخص اجرم في في حق تونس او او ربما يكون
بريئا من هذا ولاحظنا على المرات انه كثير
من الاشخاص يذهبون الى المحاكم يعني يخرج
يخرجون
فقط مراد يعقوب المعارضه على مدى تعول
السؤال الاخير باختصار لو سمحت هل هي تعول
على الشارع على
التدهور الاقتصاد على البطاله وارتفاع
الاسعار ماذا
في الواقع المعارضه تعول عن بعض المكتسبات
التي ما زالت ممنوحه في الشارع مفتكه في
الشارع من قبيله تظاهر والاعتصامات وما
الى ذلك ما زالت تعول على المواقف
الاقليميه والدوليه وخاصه تعول على
الاخطاء الكبيره التي يرتكبها قيس سعيد في
تعامله مع ملفات كان يمكن ان يتعامل معها
بطريقه افضل وبالتالي يمكن القول وهذه
حقيقه في الواقع يمكن القول ان سعايدهم
اكبر مساند للمعارضه وما يقوم به اليوم هو
ربما يساهم في تفجير برلمانه الذي وضعه
بنفسه عندما يرسل رساله بهذا الشكل حيث هو
تهديد مبطن لبقيه الاعضاء بان يلتزموا بما
يريده قيس سعيد وليس اي شيء
والمحلل السياسي وكذلك اشكر احمد الهمامي
المتحدث باسم تحالف احرار كنتما معنا من
تونس
يقد الرئيس الامريكيه اجتماعا مع رئيسي
الوزراء الاستراتي والبريطاني في القاعده
البحريه في سان دييغو القمه تهدف الى وضع
اللمسات الاخيره على تفاصيل اتفاقيه
الغواصات النوويه الاستراليه وذلك في اطار
معاهده ثلاثيه والتي تهدف لمواجهه نفوذ
الصين تنضم الان الينا من مقر انعقاد
القمه في قاعده البحريه في ساندييغو
مراسلتنا
عما يجري حتى الان ما الذي وقع الاجنده
وايضا التوقعات
اهلا ليلى قبل لحظات قليله وصل الرئيس
الامريكي الى هنا الى قاعده
في في ساندييغو وكذلك وصل كل من رئيسي
الوزراء البريطاني سوناك وكذلك الاستراليا
البانيز الى القاعده ذاتها حاليا في هذه
الاجسام من المقرر ان يعقد القاده الثلاث
لقاء قصيرا وهو متعلق
بتزويد او او بناء غواصات نوويه
لاستراليا
باستنادا الى
معاهده اوكوس الموقعه بين دول الثلاث قبل
18 شهرا هذه المعاهده امنيه وهي بالاساس
تهدف الى مواجهه
او النفوذ الصيني في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ الولايات المتحضريني على
مقاطعه فقط
لا لا اداره بايدن مع كل من اعذريني فقط
الخبر الذي وردنا البيان الامريكي
البريطاني الاسترالي المشترك والذي يتحدث
عن تدريب العسكريين الاستراليين سيبدا هذا
العام في القواعد الصناعيه للغواصات تفضلي
وجد
نعم هذا صحيح بالفعل وهذا ما قاله
في هذه الاثناء ارى وزير الدفاع الامريكي
اوستن يصل الى المنصه وكذلك
مستشار الرئيس الامريكي لشؤون الامن
القومي مايكل نيوجست
اذا نرى الان وصول وزير الدفاع الامريكي
اول الواصلين استون ومن خلفيه
المستشار الامن القومي لرئيس الامريكي
سولفان على ذكره وردا على سؤالك ليلى قال
اسام من علامات الطائره الرئاسيه
اثناء قدوم الرئيس بايدن الى هنا بانه
بالفعل سوف يتم تسليم الغواصات النوويه
لاستراليا على مدى مراحل ثلاثه الاولى
تبدا بتدريب قوات البحريه الاستراليه على
كيفيه
قيادتها وتشغيلها وايضا صيانتها المرحله
الثانيه سوف تشمل سوف تشمل
ارسال عدد من هذه الغواصات النوويه
الامريكيه الى استراليا والمرحله الثالثه
بحلول
الثلاثينيات
العقد القادم سوف يتم تسليم استراليا على
الاقل ثلاث غواصات نوويه ان لم يكن خمسه
بحسب ما قال جيك سولفان اذا تامل الولايات
المتحده ان تسلم استراليا خلال السنوات
العشر المقبله ثلاث او خمس غواصات نوويه
طبعا الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا فقط هما
حاليا الدولتان التي تمتلك اللتين تمتلكان
غواصات نوويه
ولا توجد دوله ثالثه غيرهما والان بموجب
اتفاقيه اوكوس فان الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا سوف سوف تقومان بانشاء غواصات
طويله لاستراليا ليله تفضلي
جزيلا وجد وقف اذا من سنه في ساندييغو
شكرا جزيلا لك
من سانتيجو
الان الى مزيد من الاخبار عبر العالم
منظمه هيومن رايتس واتش تقول ان السلطات
المصريه ترفض منهجيا في السنوات الاخيره
اصدار الوثائق الثبوتيه او تجديدها لعشرات
المصريين منهم صحفيون ونشط حقوق انسان
مقيمون في الخارج مشيره الى ان الرفض يهدف
على ما يبدو الى الضغط عليهم للعوده الى
مصر ليواجهوا الاضطراد او الاضطهاد عفوا
شبه المؤكد بحسب تعبير البيانات الصادره
عن المنظمه واضافت منظمه يوم
سلوك السلطات المصريه قوض قدره هؤلاء في
الخارج على السفر والعيش والعمل بشكل
قانوني
كما هدد احيانا قدرتهم على الحصول على
الرعايه الطبيه الاساسيه والخدمات
التعليميه او لمي شملهم مع افراد اسرهم
الاخرين واكدت منظمه شانها قبلت 26 شخصا
بما في ذلك صحفيون ومحامون مصريون يعيشون
في تركيا والمانيا
وماليزيا ودوله افريقيه وقطر
واستشهدت المنظمه في بيانها بما جرى مع
الزميل المذيع في الجزيره مباشر احمد طه
حين
اعاق مسؤولون في سفاره المصريه في الدوحه
تجديد جواز سفره حين رجعهم في ايلول من
عام 2021
ورغم انهم اعادوا جواز السفر للزميل طه
لكن محكمه عسكريه مصريه اصدرت لاحقا حكما
غيابيا بالسجن بحقه لخمسه عشر عاما
باكستان حيث اطلق رئيس الحكومه
الباكستانيه المقال عمران خان حمله
لانتخابيه لعضويه البرلمان المحلي في
اقليم البونجاب والمفترض تنظيمها يوم
الثلاثين من ابريل نيسان المقبل
وشارك في مسيره لانصاره ومؤيدي حزبه في
مدينه لاهور حيث يقيموا منذ تعرضه لمحاوله
اغتيال فاشله في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني
العام الماضي وكانت الحكومه المحليه
الانتقاليه في البونجاب فرضت يوم امس
قانون منع التجمعات ما تسبب في تاجيل
المسيره الى اليوم
وهنا في الدوحه يتواصل منتدى الامن
العالمي لعام 2023 والذي يناقش اعاده
تشكيل النظام العالمي المنتدى يركز على
النهج الدولي لاداره الصراعات والازمات
والتعاون ويشمل مناقشات بشان مواضيع مثل
ازمه الطاقه العالميه
ونهجه تعزيز الاقتصادات المستدامه وتنافس
القوى العظمى والذي شكلت الحرب في
اوكرانيا ذروتها كذلك يناقش دوره مجلس
الامن التابع للامم المتحده
افرجت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه عن
الاسير فؤاد الشوبكي وذلك بعد قضائه 17
عاما في سجونها وقال الشوبكي الذي يعاني
من امراض مزمنه اصيب بها خلال فتره
اعتقاله انه ماض في نضاله ضد الاحتلال
وبدورها اكدت الحكومه الفلسطينيه دعمها
للاسرى في معركتهم ضد الاجراءات العقابيه
التي فرضها الاحتلال عليهم
[تصفيق]
شيخ الاسراف ادي الشوبكي حرا طليقا
لم تعر سلطات الاحتلال اي اهتمام لامراضه
المزمنه التي اصيب بها خلال 17 عاما قضاها
داخل الاسره فقد نقلته لساعات من سجن
عسقلان الى حاجز ترخومة العسكريه جنوبي
الخليلي ليفرج عنه منه هناك في محاوله
لتلغيص عليه طبعا
امام ضريح الرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل ياسر
عرفات في رام الله اكد الشوبكي رغم كبر
سنه عزمه مواصله مسيره رفيق دربه النضالي
والثوري وفاء للشهداء والاسرى وسنواصل
الطريق اللي ابو عمار رسمها وبداها احنا
حنكمل المشوار حنكمل المشوار مهما كلف
التمن
وارواحنا رخيصه
امام وطننا امام شعبنا
اللواء الشوبكي الذي استقبل بحفاوه
الابطال في رام الله اعتقله الاحتلال عام
2006 واتهمه بالوقوف وراء تهريب سفينه
اسلحه عرفت بكارين اي عام 2002 كونه كان
يشغل في ذلك الوقت منصب رئيس الدائره
الماليه المركزيه العسكريه التابعه لاجهزه
الامن الفلسطينيه
الحكومه الفلسطينيه رحبت بالافراج عن
الشوبكي واكدت انها ماضيه في مساعيها
لنشره الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال ولن تكتمل
فرحتنا الا بتحرير كافه اسرار البواسل
الذين يخوضون معركه الحريه والكرامه
والعصيان في مواجهه البطش والتنكيل
والاجراءات الاجراميه
اسرع حريه اكثر من اربعه الاف وسبعمائه
اسير داخل المعتقلات الاسرائيليه يخوضون
منذ نحو شهر خطوات العصيان ضد اجراءات
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن
جبير واداره مصلحه السجون واكدت هيئه
الاسرى العليا ان خطواتها التصعيديه
مستمره وصولا الى الاضراب المفتوح عن
الطعام في اول ايام رمضان للضغط على
الاحتلال للعدول عن تلك الاجراءات
التعسفيه تبقى فرحه الاسير المحرر فؤاد
الشوبكي منقوصه لما تركه خلفه من فصول
معاناه يعيشها الاسرى داخل المعتقلات
الاسرائيليه معاناه تنذر بتفجر الاوضاع
الامنيه داخل السجون وخارجها في ظل
استمرار حكومه الاحتلال في فرض اجراءات
الانتقاميه بحقهم سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره
رام الله فلسطين
[موسيقى]
في مصر وعلى مدار اسبوع تتبع نشر الرسائل
مسربه لمعتقلين سياسيين في سجن بدر ثلاثاء
او ما يسمى حكوميا بمركز الاصلاح والتاهيل
يقع بدر على بعد نحو 70 كيلومترا شرق
القاهره هذا السجن سجن بدر الذي افتتح
حديثا ويعرف بالعقرب الجديد لما ينسب
لادارته من انتهاكات بحق نزلائه السياسيين
تحت عنوان انقذوا معتقلي بدر ثلاثه من
الموت تحدثت الرساله المسربه الاولى
والمؤرخه في الاول من مارس الجاري عن
الحرمان من الزياره والتريض وعن الضغط على
المعتقلين المطالبين بتلك الحقوق ما حمل
عشرات منهم على محاوله الانتحار وتحت
عنوان مجاعه قاتله اشارت احدى الرسائل
لوقف صرف الادويه الدوريه للمرضى وقالت ان
اجمالي ما يقدم للنزيل الواحد من الطعام
يصل فقط 200 جرام يوميا
وسلطه احدى الرسائل الضوء على تجاهل اداره
سجن بدر ثلاثه لما قضت به لائحه السجون
المصريه من لم يشم المعتقلين اذا كانوا
اقارب من الدرجه الاولى وقالت ان احد
المعتقلين اقدم على الانتحار كي يتمكن فقط
من رؤيه ابيه في مستشفى السجن ولكن دون
جدوى
رساله اخرى ايضا تساءلت عن امكانيه تعرف
الاهالي على ذويهم المعتقلين ان التقوا
مجددا بعد سنوات من منع زياره قبل ان
ينقلوا لبدر ثلاثه وما اصابهم في تلك
السنوات من شيب وهزال بسبب الحرمان المزمن
من الحقوق الاساسيه
على وقع تتابع تلك الرسائل وتسليط الضوء
عليها
اعلاميا سارعت وزاره الداخليه المصريه
بالنفي واتهمت في تغريده لها مقاله انها
ابواق اعلاميه تابعه لجماعه الاخوان
تحاول اثاره البلبله
السلطات المصريه تحاول اتخاذ خطوات في ملف
المعتقلين على وقع ضغوط حقوقيه دوليه طالت
لسنوات فغيرت مثلا اسم مصلحه السجون الى
قطاع الحمايه المجتمعيه وبات السجن يسمى
مركز اصلاح وتاهيل
خلال الفتره الماضيه شكلت لجان رسميا
للعفو عن المعتقلين وقد اتهمت بالتركيز
على تيارات سياسيه
واغفال اخرى
الخطوات الرسميه لم تمنع تصاعد اعداد
وفيات الاهمال الطبي بين المعتقلين
السياسيين على مدار السنوات الماضيه والتي
وصلت منذ مطلع العام الجاري فقط الى 23
حلقه
في سياق متصل يقصر القانون المصري فتره
الحبس الاحتياطي على عامين فقط بينما
تتحدث تقارير حقوقيه كثيره عن تجاوز اعداد
كبيره من المعتقلين السياسيين هذه المده
بسنوات ولكن دون مح
[موسيقى]
اكمه
وتنضم الان الينا من دبل ماري لولر
المقرره الخاصه للامم المتحده المعنيه
بالمدافعين عن حقوق الانسان اهلا وسهلا بك
سيده لورا في الحصاد كيف تقيمين الوضع في
السجون المصريه بشكل عام وفي سجن بدر
ثلاثه خاصه هل له خصوصيه يتمتع بها
في البدايه كانت هناك بعد الاشارات
المشجعه مجموعه من
حقوقيين الذين امثلهم ونتحدث عنهم هؤلاء
اناس طبعا
يعملون من اجل حقوق الاخرين تم اطلاق
صراحه سته اشخاص في بما في همه الصحفيه
ومحامي والطلبه وكانت هناك اخبار
جيده
بخصوص سيد عبد الرحمن احد او اب لاحد
وكانت هناك ايضا اتهامات
بالضروع في ارهاب اذا تم اطلاق صراحه
مجموعه من الاشخاص بما فيهم ايضا رشا عيسى
والتماثيل عامه 2022 ايضا
كانت هناك مجموعه طبعا من الاشارات للجميع
لكن لكن هناك الكثير والكثير من المشاكل
واريد الان
ان اتحدث عن حاله اربعه من الحقوقيين
الذين اتمنى ان يحضروا بعفو رئاسي
هو احد المحامين المصريين
منسق
للحقوق والحريات وتم او وقفه في 2018 اذا
تم تسجيل اختفاء مجموعه من الاشخاص لمده
ثلاث اسابيع او اربعه اسابيع الحاله التي
يتحدثون بشانها فيما يتصل بالوضع
السحليهمال الصحي
وحاله السجون طبعا هذا شيء مقلق ايضا
هدى عبد المنعم
واخرين عزه مثلا
ودين بخمسه عشره سنه والسيد عبد المنعم
بخمس سنوات وتم احضره بسياره الاسعاف الى
قاعه
المحكمه وايضا هناك متهمه اخرى اخذت
للمحكمه بالسياره الاسعاف ودينت بها عشره
فيه القضيه تتعلق
بمدافعين عن حقوق الانسان
هؤلاء لم يحضروا بمحاكمه عادله
والمحامون ايضا الذين كانوا يتولون الدفاع
عنهم لما تتح لهم فرصه الدفاع عنهم بطريقه
المثلى وهناك من لم يسمح لهم حتى
بالحديث خلال المحاكمه والادله التي يقدمت
هي كانت من الامن الداخلي ولم يكن هناك
تمحيص وتدقيق في هذه الادله ايضا المتهمون
لم يتحدثوا ولم يسمح لهم بدفاع عن انفسهم
اذا هنا نرى بشكل واضح خرق مساله
المحاكمه العادله التي لا تتوائم مع
المعايير الدوليه
بشان هذه الاسماء الاربعه التي ذكرتها هل
توصلتم مع الحكومه المصريه بشانهم وما هي
ردود الفعل التي حصلتم عليها حتى الان
يا امين
لا يتعلق الامر فقط بي انا هناك
ثلاثه واربعه رسائل رسميه ارسلت للحكومه
المصريه بخصوص هؤلاء المتهمين والحكومه
المصريه لم تقدم اي جواب ايضا اثرنا قضيه
صحه السيد عبد المنعم لم نتوصل باي جواب
لم نتوصل باي الرد
وتحدثنا عن قضيه
قانون مكافحه الارهاب تحدثنا ايضا
ان هذه القوانين ليست لا تتوائم مع
المعايير الدوله اذا لم نتوصل باي ردود في
كل هذه
القضايا انا اتمنى اتمنى ان مصر
[موسيقى]
نحن نقوم
بتحقيق في هذا الخصوص ونتواصل مع مجموعه
من الجهات احدها في
وانا لا اخذ اي قضيه
تدور حولها الشكوك اذا لا اريد ايضا ان
اتهم
بالترويج لمعلومات الزائفه بالتالي انا
دائما اتحقق من كل شيء
اجده وايضا عندما اتابع قضيه معينه عبر
مختلف دول العالم دائما اسعى للتاكد من
صدقيه وصحه المعلومات دعوني اقول ان
الحكومه المصريه وعدم ارسالها اي رد هذا
في حد ذاته مؤشر سلبي
وكانوا
قال هو في السابق انهم سيحمون حقوق
الانسان فهذا يعني ان عليهم ان يبعثوا برد
لا نريد رؤيه في مصر اي مدافع عن حقوق
الانسان ليحبس بسبب عمله السلمي وهذا كما
قلنا في تعارض صارخ مع
معايير الدوليه والموثيقه الدوليه اذا
سمحت لي سؤال اخير يتعلق بفترات الحبس
الاحتياطي التي تتجاوز العامين احيانا
بسنوات فتره العاملين التي كانت يعني
الحكومه والقانون المصري حددها
كحد اقصى ما تعليقك على ذلك
انا لا يمكنني التحدث عن هذا الامر بشكل
مفصل لكن بالنسبه لي
وضع السجون طبعا هناك مؤشرات بهذا لكن
بخصوص الشكاوى التي نتلقاها هناك
مزاعم بخصوص اوضاع السجون وهناك
اعتداء نفسي وفي احيان اخرى ايضا تعذيب
واعتداء جسدي
اشكرك جزيلا السيده ماري لولي المقرر
الخاصه للامم المتحده المعنيه بالمدافعين
عن الحقوق الانسان شكرا
[موسيقى]
وبينما ننهي الحصاد هذه ليله نسلط الضوء
على جرائم الكراهيه يقول مكتبه تحقيقات
الفيدراليه جرائم الكراهيه زادت
11.6% في عام 2021 مقارنه بعام 2020 وان
اغلبها مدفوع بتحيزات عنصريه وعرقيه ولها
علاقه بالاصول والاسلاف هذا في الولايات
المتحده طبعا التقرير الصادر اليوم يمثل
اول مره يتمكن فيها المكتب من الاعلان
بشكل موثوق عن توجهات على مستوى البلاد
تتعلق بجرائم الكراهيه وذلك منذ تحوله
لنظام جديد لجمع البيانات بعض المدن
الكبرى مثل لوس انجلوس نيويورك مشموله في
تقرير جرائم الكراهيه الذي يشمل فئات عده
في المجتمع الامريكي هي ارقام وحقائق
تذكرنا مجددا بضروره التكاتف الجميع
للتصدي لظاهره وجرائم الكراهيه عبر العالم
شكرا لكم على المتابعه
ونترككم الان مع جوله منتصف الليل مع
الاعزاء وسيله علمي